What do wisdom have you acquired in the
past few months that you want to share
with us?
Well,
I've got one.
I think I,
I've thought thought of
a bunch of new things,
but this one I'm really happy with.
Um,
I figured out why.
You know,
some of you know that there's a
mythological trope that I discussed fairly
frequently about rescuing your father
from the belly of the dragon or the belly
of the beast.
It's a motif that you see when
you see it in the lion king.
Um,
you see it when Simba is being
initiated by the baboons.
I don't remember Nephi Nitpicky,
I think his name is,
um,
after Nela humiliates him because
he's still a pathetic adolescent.
He follows the baboons.
I think it's a mandrill
actually down underground,
essentially through a long tunnel.
There's a lot of kind of scary music
in the background and the ends up
contemplating himself in a dark pool
and then his father appears in the sky.
And so that's one example of the
re construction of the mythology of
encountering your father in the abyss.
You look into the abyss
and you see your father.
And then in the Pinocchio Story,
um,
Pinocchio of course,
when he's trying to become
a genuine human being,
instead of a marionette pulled by other
people's strings or a neurotic or a,
or a liar or a jackass,
cause those are his alternate destinies.
Um,
he goes down to the darkest place he
could find the bottom of the ocean and
finds the biggest monster.
He can look at it and inside he
finds his father and in rescues him.
Um,
and the question is,
why do you find your father
when you look into the abyss?
And I really did do think I figured
this out and it's quite exciting to me.
It's such a brilliant image.
So we know as clinicians and,
and also I would say a sensible people,
but there's good clinical documentation
of this that if you find out,
imagine someone's pursuing a goal and
some of the things they have to accomplish
or confront on the way to that goal,
frightened them and they start to avoid.
And then they get more afraid.
And of course their ability to pursue
their goal or to accomplish their goal
deteriorates because they're avoiding,
if you're a psychotherapist
or even a friend or or,
or a supportive loved one,
let's say you're going to encourage the
person to face the challenges that are
making them afraid to
face them voluntarily.
And what happens as a consequence of that
is that the person usually is able to
overcome those fears and develop
the necessary skills and,
and to prevail.
And that's partly because not so
much because they get less afraid,
but because they get more
skilled and more courageous.
And so imagine that if you
bite off a little more than you can chew,
you get stronger as a consequence.
And you do that in the gym.
For example,
when you go lift weights,
you lift weights that are a
little heavier all the time.
And as a consequence,
you develop yourself physically
and you turn into who you could be.
You turned into more than you are.
Okay?
So if you face fears a
little bit at a time,
fears and challenges,
and you do that voluntarily,
then you become more than who you are.
Okay?
Now let's recast that in architectural
language and make it into a kind of
ultimate.
So,
so if you want to become
everything that you could be,
then you look into the abyss itself,
which is the darkest place that
you can possibly contemplate.
And that would be the terror of
Maura mortality and insanity and,
and of suffering and end of malevolence,
all of those.
It would be like looking into hell,
I suppose to some degree.
And then by voluntarily doing that,
then you call upon the strongest part
of yourself to respond and the strongest
part of yourself as symbolized as the
sleeping farther nested inside the beast.
And so the fundamental truth when you
look into an abyss is that you don't see
the abyss.
If you look long enough,
it's like the unanswered
to niches conundrum.
If you look long enough into a bis and
ambitious than the abyss looks into you,
it's like,
well,
if you look long enough into an abyss
passed when the abyss looks into you,
you see who you could
become in the form of your,
of the great ancestral figures nested
inside the catastrophe of life,
and then you can join them,
so to speak.
You can incorporate that
and become stronger.
And you do that partly by taking
on the challenge voluntarily.
And that informs you because you learn
when you take on challenges voluntarily.
But you also do that as a consequence
of psychophysiological transformation
because when you place yourself
in challenging situations,
let's say the abyss is the archetype of
the ultimately challenging situation,
then you turn on new genes in your nervous
system and in your body that code for
new proteins and you build
new structures inside of you.
And none of that's going to happen
without the demand that's placed on you by
willing to confront the
full terror of life.
And so then I would say the full terror
of life is something like the reality of
suffering and death.
And the ever present and the the ever
looming presence of malevolence in your
own heart and in the
heart of other people.
So it's evil and suffering and to
confront that is really well you risk
blindness by confronting that.
That's also a very old story.
You risk damaging your vision,
but if you do it forthrightly,
then you discover who you could be as a
consequence and who you could be is the
solution to malevolence and suffering.
And so that just blew me
away when I figured that out.
It was partly a consequence of,
um,
having lengthy discussions with Sam
Harris and thinking this through more and
more been pushed to think it through.
But I think that's an
absolutely staggering.
Um,
what would you call it?
Articulating that,
articulating that image fully for me.
I don't know if I've articulated it fully,
but articulating it more fully
really had a profound effect on me.
I think that's,
it's such a brilliant conceptualization
that inside the darkest place is the
heroic ancestor that whose
identity you could incorporate.
Perfect.
It's perfect.
And I really believe it's true.
And what it does is it says that human
being is actually stronger than the
greatest challenge that can
be set before him or her.
And that's really something.
I also believe it's true.
It doesn't matter how,
the other thing that's so
interesting about that is that it,
it transforms pessimism into optimism.
It's like,
well the world is a very dark place.
It's full of suffering and
it's full of malevolence.
And it might even be so full of suffering
and malevolence that a reasonable
person could question the
justification of its being a,
as Ivan Grandma's off does in,
in the brothers Karamazov
which I would highly recommend.
By the way,
that's an absolutely great book,
Dostoevsky.
Um,
but the,
the truth of the matter seems to be that
if you face the pessimism full frontal,
so to speak,
um,
then you find something in you that can,
that's strong enough to take it on.
And that's really says something about,
what would you say,
the relationship between
human beings and divinity,
I would say,
because it takes something transcendent
of transcendent power to be able to rise
above the genuine suffering
and malevolence of life.
And I do think that we have that
within us if we don't shy away from the
challenge.
So you know,
there's in the story of King
Arthur and the holy grail,
so the holy grail is one of two things.
It's a cup that either held the wine
that Christ drank at the last supper or
that was used to catch his blood
when he was speared on the cross.
Either one.
But it's the,
it's the reservoir,
let's say,
of the fluid that eternally nourishes.
It's something like that.
And when you go to look
for the holy Grail,
you don't know where to look because
you don't know where the holy grail is.
And so King Arthur and his knights
who all sit at a round table,
because there is essentially equals
each go off to find the holy grail.
And each of them enters the forest to
begin the quest at the place that looks
darkest to him.
And that's another
example of the same idea.
Is that what you and another,
it's another example of
a dictum from Carl Young,
which he extracted from the
oil chemical literature,
which was in stir Colinas infinite tour,
which means roughly speaking in filth
that will be found or more to the point
what you most need will be found
where you least want to look,
but you have to look purposefully.
If it chases you,
you're prey.
If you confront it,
then you're the thing
that can transcend it.
And that's a unbelievably optimistic
message because it suggests that if you're
willing to take on the burden of being
with it's suffering and malevolence,
that you can awaken that with
that which is within you,
that will allow you to prevail and God
only knows how deep an idea that is.
It might be the deepest of ideas because
who knows what the limit of a human
being is so well that's some
of the wisdom so to speak,
that have acquired in the last few months
and there's quite a bit more too and,
but I'm going to write all this down
and hopefully publish a bunch of it.
And my next book I figured out a bunch
about hierarchies to and how they
function.
And a whole,
I've developed a whole new
way of conceptualizing.
One of the things I was arguing with
about Sam arguing with about with Sam
Harris was the relationship
between facts and values.
Because Sam and he has his reasons.
We'd like to propose that we can
derive values directly from facts.
And he wants to do that because he
wants to nail the world of values to
something solid so it
doesn't float in air and,
and,
and get,
let's say,
um,
what would you call it?
Hijacked by the fundamentalists
or dissolve into nihilism.
And both of those are terrible
ends for a hierarchy of value.
So he wants to nail it to
something more objective and,
and less relativistic and less,
less grounded in revealed truth
that removes it from the domain of
fundamentalism.
And so I can understand his point
and why he wants to do that.
But the problem is is that it isn't
easy to derive values from facts because
there's an infinite number of facts and
by necessity a very finite number of
values.
In fact,
most of the time when
you're doing something,
you're reducing the whole world to one
value and that value is encapsulated in
whatever goal you happen to be pursuing
at the moment or whatever you're paying
attention to,
which is also a form of
goal directed pursuit.
And so I've also figured out that,
and I kind of knew this,
but I could articulate it better now,
that you look at the world of facts
through a hierarchy of values and that
hierarchy of values is instantiated in
your nervous system and Simile Tanium as
a social construct because you pay
attention to things of value that you and
everyone else have established as
valuable through a process of social
negotiation.
And you need to pay attention to
what you think that's valuable,
that everyone else thinks is valuable
because otherwise you wouldn't have any
basis for shared attention
and you wouldn't have any
basis for trade with other
people.
So that's another thing.
So that's really been helpful because,
so now I figured out that you reduce the
infinite world of facts to the finite
world of values by viewing the world
of facts through what's essentially a
dominance hierarchy of value.
And that's,
and that that exists both
out in the social world and
neurologically at the same
time.
And so that's been unbelievably
useful to figure out too.
And a part of a mystery that I'd been
trying to untangle for about three
decades.
So.